مساء الخير،
نذر المستشرق الفرنسي لوي ماسينيون كل حياته تقريبا،
لدراسة الحسين بن منصور الحلاج،
ليترك لنا عند وفاته سنة 1962 أثرا ضخما حول الحلاج،
صدر في أربعة أجزاء عن دار النشر الفرنسية الشهيرة "غاليمار".
وحمل عنوان : La Passion de Hallaj.
وتُرجم إلى العربية تحت عنوان آلام الحلاج،
الجزء الأوّل،
وهو الرئيس، وعنوانه؛ La Vie de Hallaj,
حياة الحلاج،
ويتناول حياة الحلاج منذ ولادته سنة 244 هجري،
إلى تاريخ وفاته مصلوبا في بغداد سنة 309 هجرية،
ويتكون هذا الجزء من 708 صفحة.
الجزء الثاني،
ويتكون من 511 صفحة،
وحمل عنوان؛ La Survie de Hallaj.
الحلاج على قيد الحياة،
أي كيف وصلنا أثر الحلاج بعد صلبه وحرق معظم كتبه،
وفيه يتناول لوي ماسينيون بدقة متناهية،
الأسانيد
التي نقلت لنا أفكار الحلاج من الفقهاء والمؤرخين،
من خصومه والمتعاطفين معه كذلك على امتداد الف عام.
أما الجزء الثالث والمتكون من 381 صفحة،
وحمل عنوان؛ La Doctrine de Hallaj,
عقيدة الحلاج،
وفيه يتناول لوي ماسينيون الاصول الفكرية لمذهب الحلاج.
اما الجزء الرابع والأخير،
والمتكون من 330 صفحة،
وهو خاص ببيبلوغرافيا أبحاث لوي ماسينيون حول الحلاج،
ونجد فيه كل المؤلفات التي اقتفى فيها لوي ماسينيون أثر الحلاج  لإعداد هذا المؤلف الضخم،
فقد اطلع لوي ماسينيون على 932 مؤلفا لستمائة وستة وثلاثين كاتبا،
منهم،
ثلاثمائة وواحد وخمسين كاتبا عربيا
ومائة وستة وثلاثين كاتبا أوروبيا،
وخمسة وسبعون كاتبا فارسيا،
وخمسين كاتبا تركيا،
وخمسة  كتّاب ماليزيين،
وستة كتّاب هنود،
وكاتبين سريانين،
وكاتبين  يهوديين.
حياة الحلاج هي المحور الرئيسي الذي يدور حوله هذا الكتاب،
ولكن  قلم لوي ماسينيون عند تعقّبه لأثر الحلاج،
سيحملنا في رحلة ممتعة عبر الزمن،
لنكتشف حواضر الخلافة العباسية،
بمعمارها وأحيائها ومساجدها وحمّاماتها وجسورها،
في النصف الثاني من القرن الثالث هجري وبداية القرن الرابع هجري.
سيأخذنا إلى شوارع وازقة بغداد،
وسيتمكن حتى من إحصاء عدد سكانها وقتئذ،
استنادا إلى كمية المؤونة، التي تستهلكها عاصمة الخلافة العباسية،
فكان عدد سكان بغداد في تقديره في بداية القرن الرابع للهجرة،
في حدود المليون ونصف المليون ساكن،
كانت بغداد من أكبر الحواضر في العالم.
وقام لوي ماسينيون بقياس مساحتها،
فكانت في حدود 9286 هكتارا،
سنة 303 هجرية الموافق ل 915 ميلادية،
وقارنها بمساحة باريس سنة 1789،
عند اندلاع الثورة الفرنسية أي بعد 874 عاما،
والتي لم تتجاوز مساحتها حدود 7000 هكتار.
سيحدثنا لوي ماسينيون عن بغداد عاصمة الفكر والثقافة،
عن مدارس علم الكلام،
عن مدارس التصوف،
عن مذاهب الفقهاء،
عن المعتزلة و الأشاعرة والحنابلة،
عن الشعر والشعراء،
عن الوراقين، عن حركة الترجمة،
سوف يحدثنا عن الصراعات السياسية و الانتفاضات التي شهدتها الخلافة،
عن ثورة الزنج، عن ثورة القرامطة،
عن الشيعة العلويين والإسماعيلية،
سيحدثنا عن الشعوبية و الصراع بين الفرس والاتراك والعرب،
سيحدثنا كذلك عن الدسائس في قصر الخليفة العباسي المقتدر بالله،
عن نفوذ الجواري والغلمان، وسلطة والدته شغب،
وعن صراع الوزراء وقادة الجيش والفقهاء.
كل هذا في أسلوب بديع وبلغة مليئة بالأشجان،
لوي ماسينيون سيقوم بعملية تقمّص عاطفي لشخصية الحسين  بن منصور الحلاج،
ويجعل من قلمه ترجمانا للغة الهيجان الروحي التي نجدها في طواسين الحلاج.
كان الحلاج،
يقول دائما في دعواته؛
"يا معين الفناء عليّ، اعنّي على الفناء"،
ويبدو ان الله قد استجاب لدعائه،
وانتصر الحلاج على الفناء الوجودي والنسيان،
ويعود الجزء الأكبر في ذلك إلى المستسرق الفرنسي لوي ماسينيون،
الذي جعل من مأساة الحلاج أسطورة مجنحة.
استمعوا إلى لوي ماسينيون،
وهو يتحدّث عن أوّل لقاء له مع أثر الحلاج في القاهرة،
من خلال كتاب "تذكرة الأولياء" لفريد الدين العطّار.
التقيت الحلاج،
في ربيع مصري حارق دون نقاء،
اين كنت أبحث،
عن ينابيع للإرتواء من الحياة، والتي يجب أن تكون الحياة الأبدية،
وفي يوم ما،
احد اصدقائي الذي كان يفكّر في نوع آخر من الحياة،
وكان يتقن العربية جيدا، واعتنق الإسلام،
قال لي انت تحب، وترغب ان تعتقد انك تحب الله،
الله يجب أن يُعتقد فيه،
ذكر خالد لا يتغير،
نحن نحب اي شيء، نحب خياناتنا،
الحب لم يُجعل للإله،
ورغم ذلك يوجد مسلما يعتبره الكثير وليا صالحا،
مات بسبب عشقه لله، فقد استسلم لآلام الصليب حبا في الإله،
ومدني بكتاب، كان بالفارسية،
لأن هذا المتصوّف الذي يُتحدّث عنه بالعربية،
من المرجح انه لا يتكلم الفارسية، لكنه ولد ببلاد فارس،
وفي بلاد فارس نذكره أكثر،
وفي بلاد فارس كذلك نذكر أكثر آلام الذي حمل اسم حفيد الرسول، الحسين، الذي قتل في كربلاء.
اعتقد ان الحلاج قد حمل اسم الحسين عن امه،
فالأم هي التي تمنح الاسم لطفلها، وتعطيه مصيره، وهي تتصوره ولا تفهمه.
الحلاج أُحتفي به بصورة خاصة من طرف شعراء فرس كبار مثل حافظ وقبله العطّار،
الكتاب الذي قدمه لي صديقي كان، "تذكرة الأولياء" للعطّار،
في ترجمة فرنسية جميلة لصاحبتها Pavet de Courteille,
نقلا عن ترجمة أيغورية، وهو امر مثير للدهشة.
Pavet de Courteille  تركت في النص الإيغوري بعض الحكم بالعربية،
وهو ما ساعدني لأنني مستعرب، ساعدني على فهم البقية،
واحدى هذه الحكم اصابتنى كالسهم،
وهي؛ ركعتان في العشق لا يصح وضوءهما إلا بالدم،
ركعتان فقط كافيتين في صلاة العشق ولكنهما لا تصحّا الا اذا كان وضوءهما بالدم.
ولد الحسين بن منصور الحلاج في بلدة تور في الشمال الشرقي من مدينة البيضاء ببلاد فارس
سنة 244 هجري الموافق ل 857 ميلادي،
وهي نفس المدينة التي ولد فيها النحوي الكبير سبويه.
يقول ابن كثير متحدّثا عن الحلاّج؛
"هو الحسين بن منصور بن محمي الحلاج،
ابو المغيث، ويقال ابو عبد الله، كان جده ماجوسيا، اسمه محمي،
من اهل فارس من بلدة يقال لها البيضاء. ونشأ بواسط، ويقال بتُستَر."
ابن كثير، البداية والنهاية، ج 11 ، ص 132.
اختلفت الروايات حول أصل لقبه، الحلاج،
الرواية الأولى تقول انه نسبة لوالده  الذي كان يحلج القطن،
اما الرواية الثانية فتقول انه جاء لمدينة واسط،
فنزل في دكّان قطّان (اي تاجر قطن) وطلب منه ان يساعده في قضاء شغل،
ولكن الرجل قال له انه مشغول وله كمية كبيرة من القطن عليه حلجها،
فقال له الحسين؛ اذهب في إصلاح شغلي، فإني اعينك على عملك،
فذهب الرجل،
فلما رجع رأى كل قطنه محلوجا،
وكان أربعة وعشرين الف رطل،
فسمي منذ ذلك اليوم بالحلاج،
اما الرواية الثالثة التي يذكرها ابن كثير،
فتقول ان اهل الأهواز أطلقوا عليه هذه التسمية،
لأنه كان يكاشفهم بما في قلوبهم، فسموه بحلاج الأسرار أي كاشف الأسرار.
نشأ الحلاج في مدينة واسط بالعراق،
التي استقر فيها والده بعد أن غادر بلدة تور الفارسية،
مدينة واسط التي اسسها الحجاج بن يوسف الثقفي سنة 78 هجرية،
كانت في ذلك الوقت مركز إشعاع روحي وفكري كبيرين،
أسس فيها الأشاعرة مدرستهم الكبرى،
وأسس فيها الحنابلة مدرسة للقرّاء ومعهدا للحديث،
وكانت مساجدها مسرحا للجدل والحوار بين مختلف المدارس الفقهية والكلامية،
إذن نشأ الحلاج في هذا الجو الفكري والثقافي الخلاّق،
ولفت الانتباه اليه منذ نعومة اظافره بذكائه الحاد واقباله على العلم والمعرفة،
حفظ القرآن وهو في سن الثانية عشرة،
وأقبل  على علوم عصره من فقه وتفسير وحديث وحكمة وتصوّف،
وفي سن السادسة عشرة سافر إلى مدينة تُستر الفارسية،
ليتعلّم على يد احد اعلام الصوفية في عصره وهو الإمام سهل بن عبد الله التُستري،
أُعجب الحلاج بشخصية شيخه ولازمه مدة سنتين استوعب خلالها أصول المنهج الصوفي.
بعد ذلك غادر الحلاج تُستر باتجاه البصرة،
حيث تتلمذ على يد الشيخ الصوفي عمر المكي والذي البسه الخرقة الصوفية،
وهي ثوب ممزّق من الصوف الخشن، يُلبسه الشيخ مريده،
علامة للتفويض والتسليم، ولا يمنحه إياه إلا بعد أن يقضي مرحلة رياضية روحية خاصة،
ومنه على الأرجح جاءت كلمة التصوّف.
تزوج الحلاج في البصرة بأم الحسين بنت يعقوب الأقطع احد أعيان المدينة،
ورُزق منها بثلاثة أبناء،
وهي المرأة الوحيدة في حياة الحلاج وظلّت إلى جانبه في ذروة محنته.
ثم قرر الحلاج مغادرة البصرة،
بعد خلاف حاد نشب بينه وبين شيخه عمر المكي ليستقرّ في بغداد عاصمة الخلافة،
اين التحق بدروس الشيخ ابي القاسم الجنيد احد أقطاب الصوفية،
ولكن سرعان ما فترت العلاقة بينهما،
فشخصية الحلاج شخصية قلقة ومتمردة
ولم يقبل فكرة ان يستسلم المريد لشيخه استسلاما كاملا كما يقتضيه المنهج الصوفي التقليدي.
يقول لوي ماسينيون؛
"سرعان ما راح الحلاج  يبحث عن المعنى الرمزي الذي يرفع دعاء الروح إلى الله".
ومنذ ذلك الحين قرر الحلاج ان يستقل بنفسه،
وان يسلك طريقه الى الله بمفرده،
ولمّا سُئل عن المريد قال؛
"هوّ الرامي بأول قصده إلى الله تعالى، ولا يُعرّج حتى يصل."
بعد أن أُخمدت ثورة الزنج، شدّ الحلاج الرحال لأداء مناسك الحج،
ونذر نفسه بالبقاء عاما كاملا للعمرة وهو في حالة صوم عن الطعام والكلام،
اقتداء بمريم العذراء التي فعلت هذا استعدادا لميلاد كلمة الله فيها.
يقول أبو يعقوب النهر جوري، وهو من أقطاب التصوف السني في القرن الرابع للهجرة؛
"دخل الحلاج مكة أول دخلةٍ،
وجلس في صحن المسجد سنةً لم يبرح من موضعه إلا للطهارة والطواف،
ولم يحترز من الشمس ولا من المطر،
وكان يُحمل اليه في كل عشية كوز ماء، وقرصٌ من أقراص مكة،
وكان عند الصباح يُرى القرص على رأس الكوز وقد عُضّ منه ثلاثُ عضّات أو أربعةٌ فيحمل من عنده."
هذه الخلوة الروحية في مكّة كانت مفصلية في حياة الحلاج،
قال بعدها هذه الكلمات الوجدية لمريديه الذين سمّاهم الأصحاب والخلاّن؛
قال؛ " لو أُلقي مما في قلبي ذرّة على جبال الأرض لذابت".
فكر الحلاج هو جزء من الفكر الصوفي،
والتصوّف له معجم خاص، يختلف عن معجم الفقهاء،
التصوّف هدفه بناء الفرد، ومحاولة الوصول إلى المعنى الحقيقي للإيمان،
وسبل التواصل بين الصوفي وخالقه لا علاقة لها بمدونات الفقهاء،
فهو ينتج لغته الخاصة القائمة على الإلهام والنظر الكشفي والذوقي،
وحرية المتصوّف تتجاوز حرية الفقيه في استنطاق النص المقدّس ،
ففي حين يعتمد الفقيه في قراءة النص على آلية التعبد الآلي،
يعتمد المتصوف على آلية التعبد المعنوي.
يقول الحلاج متحدثا عن خالقه:
رَأَيـتُ رَبّـي بِـعَينِ قَلبي، فَـقُلتُ مَـن أَنتَ قالَ أَنتَ...
فَـلَيسَ لِـلأَينِ مِـنكَ أَيـنٌ، وَلَـيسَ أَيـنٌ بِـحَيثُ أَنتَ...
أَنـتَ الَّـذي حُزتَ كُلَّ أَينٍ بِـنَحوِ لا أَيـن ثـم أَنتَ...
فَـفي فَـنائي فَـنا فَـنائي، وَفـي فَـنائي وُجِدتَ أَنتَ...
في مَحو اِسمي وَرَسمِ جِسمي سَـأَلتُ عَـني فَـقُلتُ أَنتَ...
أَنـتَ حَـياتي وَسِـرُّ قَلبي فَـحَيثُما كُـنتُ كُـنتَ أَنتَ...
فَـمُـنَّ بِـالعَفوِ يـا إِلَـهي فَـلَيسَ أَرجـو سِواكَ أَنتَ...
استمعوا إلى هذه الكلمات الرائعة للحلاّج بصوت الفنان العراقي كاظم الساهر.
رَأَيـتُ رَبّـي بِـعَينِ قَلبي، فَـقُلتُ مَـن أَنتَ قالَ أَنتَ...
فَـلَيسَ لِـلأَينِ مِـنكَ أَيـنٌ، وَلَـيسَ أَيـنٌ بِـحَيثُ أَنتَ...
أَنـتَ الَّـذي حُزتَ كُلَّ أَينٍ
بِـنَحوِ لا أَيـن فأين أَنتَ...
ففي بقائي ولا بقائي وَفـي فَـنائي وُجِدتَ أَنتَ...
في مَحو اِسمي وَرَسمِ جِسمي
في مَحو اِسمي وَرَسمِ جِسمي سَـأَلتُ عَـني فَـقُلتُ أَنتَ...
أَنـتَ حَـياتي وَسِـرُّ قَلبي
أَنـتَ حَـياتي وَسِـرُّ قَلبي فَـحَيثُما كُـنتُ كُـنتَ أَنتَ...
فَـمُـنَّ بِـالعَفوِ يـا إِلَـهي فَـلَيسَ أَرجـو سِواكَ أَنتَ...
فَـمُـنَّ بِـالعَفوِ يـا إِلَـهي...
فَـمُـنَّ بِـالعَفوِ...
يـا إِلَـهي...
فَـمُـنَّ بِـالعَفوِ يـا إِلَـهي فَـلَيسَ أَرجـو سِواكَ أَنتَ...
أَنـتَ حَـياتي، أَنـتَ حَـياتي، وَسِـرُّ قَلبي...
يـا إِلَـهي...
فَـمُـنَّ بِـالعَفوِ يـا إِلَـهي فَـلَيسَ أَرجـو سِواكَ أَنتَ...
صورة الإله عند المتصوّف ليست هي نفسها صورة الاله عند الفقيه،
العلاقة بين المتصوّف وخالقه تقوم على المحبة،
في حين ان العلاقة بين الفقيه وخالقه تقوم على الخوف،
لذلك تصوّر الاله عند الفقيه هو الأقرب إلى عامة الناس،
فهو إلاه الوعد والوعيد، إله الجنة والنار بينما إله المتصوّف هو إله العشق والمحبّة،
الارتباط بين المخلوق و الخالق في الفكر الصوفي
هو ارتباط وجداني بعيدا عن الخوف من العقاب أو الطمع في الثواب،
كانت رابعة العدوية مؤسسة مذهب الحب الإلاهي
في القرن الثاني للهجرة تردد دائما؛
"ربي ما عبدتك طمعاً في جنتك ولا خوفاً من نارك وإنما عبدتك لأنك تستحق العبادة"،
والحلاج يذهب ابعد من ذلك في تطرّفه في محبّته لذات الله عندما يقول؛
أُريدُكَ لا أُريدُكَ لِلثَوابِ
وَلَكِن أُريدُكَ لِلعِقابِ
فَكُلُّ مَآرِبي قَد نِلتُ مِنها
سِوى مَلذوذِ وَجدي بِالعَذابِ.
قضّىى الحلاج الجزء الأكبر من حياته في السفر والترحال،
بعد عودته من مكة سافر إلى الأهواز داعيا الناس إلى الزهد والتقرّب إلى الله،
وقد عظم شأنه هناك واتبعه الناس ورددوا كراماته،
ثم رحل إلى خراسان مع عشرات من مريديه ينشر دعوته التي وصل صداها لعاصمة الخلافة بغداد،
ثم قام برحلة كبرى عبر البحر إلى بلاد الهند والسند،
ووصل إلى مشارف الصين يستطلع أحوال الأمم والشعوب الأخرى من غير المسلمين.
وبعد أن طاف بمشارق الأرض ومغاربها، عاد إلى بغداد سنة 296 هجري،
وقد سبقته اخبار كراماته وخوارقه التي تناقلتها عامة الناس وجعلت منها أساطير،
وساهم كذلك خصومه في ترويجها لإتهامه في ما بعد بالسحر والشعوذة والزندقة.
فقيل أنه كان يُخرج فاكهة الشتاء في الصيف،
وفاكهة الصيف في الشتاء،
ويمد يده في الهواء فيعيدها مملوءةً دراهم،
وقد كتب عليها، قل هو الله أحد، ويسميها دراهم القدرة.
يقول صاحب  كتاب، تاريخ بغداد، الخطيب البغدادي:
«اختلف الناس في أمره،
فقال قومٌ: ساحرٌ!
وقال قومٌ: مجنون!
وقال قومٌ: له الكرامات، وإجابة الدعوات.»
الحلاج، كان عندما تعجز الكلمة على حمل فكرته،
يعمد إلى الرمز
والصورة
وأحيانا إلى المعادلة الرياضية.
يقول مثلا في تفسيره لفكرة وحدة الوجود:
" النقطة اصل كل خط،
والخط كله نقط مجتمعة،
فلا غنى للخط عن النقطة، ولا للنقطة عن الخط،
وكل خط مستقيم او منحرف هو متحرك عن النقطة بعينها،
وكل ما يقع عليه بصر احد فهو نقطة بين نقطتين،
وهذا دليل على تجلي الحق من كل ما يشاهد،
وتَرائيه عن كل ما يعاين،
ومن هذا قلت ما رأيت شيئا الا رأيت الله فيه "
الحظوة التي نالها الحلاج عند عودته إلى بغداد،
سوف تجلب له عداوة الفقهاء من مختلف المذاهب،
والساسة في قصر الخلافة وحتى المتصوفة وعلى رأسهم معلميه  الجنيد وعمر المكي.
لأن الحلاج انتقد سلبية المتصوفة من معاصريه،
الذي قنعوا بعبادة الله، غير مهتمين بواجباتهم تجاه الناس.
فثار على زهد أبي يزيد البسطامي وعلى تقية الجنيد وعلى سلبية عمر المكي،
وأسس منهجًا جديدًا في التصوف،
يرى أن التصوف جهادٌ في سبيل إحقاق الحق،
وليس مسلكًا فرديًا بين المتصوف والخالق فقط،
فجعله جهادًا ضد النفس وكذلك جهادا ضد الظلم والطغيان في المجتمع .
الحلاج كان حاملا لروح قطب صوفي ثائر، ولقلب محب عابد، ولعقل زعيم مدبّر كذلك.
يقول لوي ماسنيون:
«إن الحلاج أحيا بمنهجه هذا، وبحميته الثائرة، و بشخصيته الباهرة،
الآمال العريضة، والأحلام الجميلة، التي كانت تعيش في أعماق الأمة الإسلامية،
فالتفّت حوله الجماهير، واندفع في تياره كثير من الأمراء والوزراء والقادة.»
هذا المنهج الصدامي الذي قطع مع تقية التصوّف التقليدي،
سوف يؤدي إلى سجنه مدة تسع سنوات،
و محاكمته ثلاث مرّات،
وصلبه سنة 309 هجري في بغداد.
اتوقف عند هذا الحد،
لأعود لكم في الحلقة القادمة لأحدثكم عن سجن الحلاج ومحاكماته الثلاث،
وعن الدسائس داخل قصر الخليفة العباسي المقتدر بالله،
وكيف أقنعه وزيره حامد بن العباس بالموافقة على تنفيذ حكم الصلب و الإعدام في حق الحسين بن منصور الحلاج.
اشكركم على المتابعة،
والى اللقاء في الحلقة القادمة على قناة أنا أفكر إذن أنا موجود...